[Applause]
they're going nuts back there it's so
funny
her partner in the song was holding his
Oscar and he said let's have them kiss
and she said but they're both guys and
so he goes but it's Hollywood
so I thought you'd enjoy that our next
presenter is talented and beautiful
apparently that's what you need to get
ahead in this town
please welcome Cameron Diaz
[Music]
[Applause]
eighty Oscars ago the first award for
cinema under cinematography oh I can do
it went to a silent movie called sunrise
the three lead characters were called in
the actual script the man the wife and
the woman from the city
sounds like a fun shoot from that first
job of framing those faces - today the
cinematographers have captured the most
memorable images of movie history for
the best cinematography the nominees are
Roger Deakins for the assassination of
Jesse James by the Coward Robert Ford
Seamus McGarvey for Atonement longish
Kaminski for the diving bell and the
butterfly Roger Deakins for No Country
for Old Men
Robert Ellsworth for there will be blood
and the Oscar goes to for there will be
blood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the first Academy Award a second
nomination for Bob Adele's which he was
previously nominated in this category
for good night and good luck
[Music]
John's whole when does the number of
years ago said that the production
designer in his movie that that that
fifty percent of it belonged to him well
80 percent belongs to Jack Fiske and his
production team and David Frank and
Dylan Tichenor but really we all know it
really really belongs to Paul that this
is his imagination and his energy and
his extraordinary vision and it sort of
enabled us to create the world of there
will be blood
thank you Paul but we're really all
standing on the shoulders we know this
of Daniel day-lewis who isn't here right
now but thank you all so much thank you
and Helen thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]